dans ce salon de coiffure les clients
sont traités aux petits soins mais ces
petits soins viennent avec un coup élevé
pour la nature
cheveux coupés excédent de coloration
métaux usagés article à usage unique
l'industrie de la coiffure à elle seule
au Canada et aux États-Unis produiraient
plus de 200000 kg de déchets tous les
jours c'est énorme pour l'industrie
beauté qui va créer la beauté à toutes
les jours un sentiment bien-être
malheureusement le l'autre côté c'est
que ça pollue énormément la planète
Mathieu Mainville qui soucieux de
réduire l'empreinte écologique de son
entreprise a choisi de souscrire au
programme de récupération de green
circle une entreprise canadienne qui
récupère jusqu'à 95% des déchets de
salon de coiffure et qui affirme en
revaloriser la presque totalité ça fait
partie
toujours chez nous compost et compagnie
c'est juste naturel d'inclure ça dans
mon commerce le fonctionnement est
simple Mathieu et son équipe dépose les
résidus dans divers contenants
et tout est envoyé ici dans cette
entrepôt de Toronto
les matières sont priées nettoyer ici et
envoyer ensuite chez des recycleurs
spécialisés les métaux sont fondus pour
en faire des feuilles ou des barres
d'aluminium l'huile et l'eau de la
coloration sont séparés l'huile sert
ensuite à faire de l'énergie les cheveux
peuvent servir des fonds à pétrole lors
de déversements 1 kg de cheveux absorbez
8 litres de pétrole ils peuvent aussi
être composés et transformés le cheveux
sur une matière qui est quand même assez
résistante qui est assez flexible c'est
qu'on a des projets d'innovation comme
de filtration et d'isolation mais depuis
aussi été capable de créer un
bioplastique à ce jour ce sont environ
5000 salons de coiffure en Amérique du
Nord qui adhèrent au programme de green
circle le service vient avec un coût une
mensualité qui varie selon le nombre de
clients c'est comme pays des impôts si
on ça coûte cher les impôts mais ça a
l'air bénéfice important positif pour la
société Mathieu Mainville absorbe une
partie des coûts et le client lui en
paye aussi une partie un éco-frère de 2
dollars si j'avais à choisir entre un
salon qui utilise ces pratiques là ou
pas c'est sûr que je privilégie cette
pratique les clients sont soulagés pour
vrai c'est je pense que ça fait partie
des valeurs de pas mal que tout le monde
tout le monde cherche à faire ce petit
geste qui fait la différence dans le
quotidien qui aura un impact positif
d'autres petits gestes peuvent être
bénéfiques pour l'environnement comme
choisir des produits plus écologiques
lavez vos cheveux moins souvent et bien
sûr diminuer la fréquence de vos visites
chez votre coiffeur préféré ici Elisa
serrer Radio-Canada à Montréal